PETER READ: Hi.
RUBY WAX: Hi.
PETER READ: Could we just get
a sense of who's in the room?
RUBY WAX: Names.
No.
PETER READ: Yeah,
specific names.
Like product versus engineering,
and product versus commercial,
how many product-y
engineering-y types?
Yeah, that's right.
We're in CSG, aren't we?
OK, and then commercial?
Yeah, almost everybody.
Got it.
And then in terms of
familiarity, how many have
done Search Inside Yourself?
Oh, actually quite a few.
Brilliant.
And Headspace or gPause
or any [INAUDIBLE].
What is that?
About half?
Something like that?
All right.
As Sasha said, we're keen,
very happy to make this
as interactive as you guys like.
What we thought we might do is I
can talk a little bit about why
resilience is important.
I'll do the nerdy bit, why
She'll then do the really
funny bit, all the magic
about how you actually
build resilience and avoid
becoming frazzled.
And then what we'd
actually love to do
is bring it together in Q&A
afterwards to the extent
that you guys are
interested, is how can we
work with Google harnessing
your tech, either hardware
or software, to solve
mental well-being in a way--
and not just for Googlers, but
for everyone-- and in a way
to do-- can we do for
mental well-being what
Deep Mind with their
NHS partnership is doing
for physical well-being?
We think that would be a fun
thing to explore with you guys
if you're up for it.
That makes sense?
About right?
So if I start with why
resilience is important-- so
what I do as an angel
investor and now
as an investor with Vitruvian,
a big growth equity investment
fund, is we help entrepreneurs.
We embolden entrepreneurs to
understand the risks that they
are taking and then to help them
build the resilience in order
to deal with taking those risks.
And just sort of
winding it back,
I think it's always
helpful at these things
to frame this and
really understand
what we're talking about.
So whether you're at
Google as an innovator
or a disrupter
within a big company,
or you're an entrepreneur
like a CityMapper founder,
your job is to take risks.
And I always think
it's really helpful
to unpick that a little
bit and understand
what risks you're taking
and then why resilience
is important.
So in terms of the risks
that people in this room
are probably taking, we often
start with product risk.
And, actually, Google, I
think, as a company generally,
most people at Google take
quite a bit of product risk.
In other words,
you're inventing.
You're bringing new
products to the world.
And the way you measure
that is product market
fit and traction.
It's not always the way.
There are other groups, other
entrepreneurs who prefer
not to take product risks.
So they all take a
fairly familiar product.
But they will take market risks.
So they'll take a
familiar product,
but then they will build
it in an unfamiliar market.
So just as legitimate
as a strategy,
but a very, very different
sort of set of risks.
Whether you're taking
product risk or market risk,
you definitely also
take execution risk.
So getting stuff done.
And in my world, in
the investment world,
we never back ideas.
We back teams.
We back people who
get stuff done.
Which is sort of a common
misconception fueled
by Dragon's Den and others.
So that's what we do.
And I think it's
really important
to sort of start
there and ground it
in this is all about people
who take risks-- as I said,
whether those people are
entrepreneurs in a startup
or whether they're
innovators disrupters
within a big
company like Google.
And then just pause
there for a second
and reflect on that
because I think
most of us in the
real world spend
most of our time trying
to eliminate risk
or at least mitigate
it and box it in.
And yet we're now talking
about disrupters and innovators
within a big company or startup
entrepreneurs who deliberately
invite more risk into
their lives, which
is a fairly bonkers thing
to do if you think about it.
And in my experience,
it very rarely
ends up being contained at
just professional risk, risk
that I take during work.
It very often-- especially for
the startup entrepreneurs--
ends up being risk
that in a porous way
filters into their real life,
so risk to their health,
risk to their relationships,
risk to their house,
their mortgage.
So, , again, we start from
a fairly curious place.
These are people who
deliberately invite risk
into their lives.
So here's the bit
about resilience.
And I'm often asked,
what is it that I
look for when I make an
angel investment or any kind
of investment.
And it is always-- if I had to
pick one characteristic that I
always look for in
the entrepreneurs
that I back, it
would be resilience.
And so what do I mean by that?
There are two ways of thinking
about resilience in my book.
One is around protecting the
downside of entrepreneurship
or innovation.
And another is
unlocking the upside.
So starting with
protecting the downside,
I think resilience
for me is the ability
to manage stress and anxiety.
You will be told,
as an innovator
in a big company
or an entrepreneur,
you'll be told no 1,000 times.
That's a stupid idea.
Get out of my office.
That can't be done.
So how do you pick
yourself up from that?
It tends to be a fairly
anxiety-inducing environment.
So how do you manage your
own stress and anxiety
within a situation like that?
The second aspect
of it is the ability
to make decisions in
highly ambiguous, highly
uncertain, highly
volatile situations.
That's what all of you
do when you're being
innovative in a big company.
It's what entrepreneurs
do when they're
being innovative in
a startup context.
So that's the protecting
the downside bit.
Those are the characteristics
of resilience that we look for.
And then in terms of
unlocking the upside,
let me ask a question.
Who can tell me the
opposite of fragile?
What's the opposite of fragile?
Any words or phrases
spring to mind?
AUDIENCE: Robust.
PETER READ: Sorry?
PETER READ: Robust.
It's a great one.
Sorry, there was
another one there?
AUDIENCE: Strong.
PETER READ: Strong.
Yeah.
And those are all good.
And that's exactly where
I started when asked
exactly the same question.
And so in a way, though,
robust and strong--
if fragile is falls over when
risk or volatility, uncertainty
comes along, strong
and robust just means
can withstand uncertainty,
volatility, risk.
And Nassim Taleb, who wrote
"The Black Swan," which I think
is an amazing book,
wrote another book
called "Antrifragile"
because he said
there isn't a word for
the opposite of fragile.
In the sense that what is it--
and he describes innovators
and entrepreneurs in
this way-- what is it
that not just can
withstand risk, volatility,
and uncertainty, but positively
blossoms and flourishes
with more risk?
And again, that's a
pretty unusual concept.
And he said entrepreneurs,
innovators are such people.
And the way he describes it,
I think it's really, really
powerful-- very, very
interesting-- is innovators,
entrepreneurs are--
they open themselves
up to risk and
uncertainty because risk
is information rich.
It's rich in information
about your competitors,
about your customers,
about your investors.
So if you open yourself
up to it, yes, it's scary.
But actually, it means
that you're nimble.
You're on your feet.
You're getting all
the information
about the marketplace.
So risk is information
rich, I think,
is an incredibly
powerful insight.
And for me, it helps explain why
entrepreneurs do what they do,
innovators do what they do.
They open themselves up to risk.
So that's how I often
think about resilience.
That's what I look for in the
entrepreneurs that I back.
So it's relatively easy to
describe what resilience is.
There's a neuroscience
definition
of it, actually,
around neuroplasticity.
She knows.
She'll tell you what that means.
And so I hope that
helps frame it in terms
of why resilience is important.
And now Ruby is going
to talk about how
to actually build resilience.
RUBY WAX: Well, I think
one in a million--
or maybe those aren't the
statistics-- would get pleasure
out of not being sure because
the human condition is
that's terrifying unless
you have Asperger's and you
don't have to
concentrate on emotions.
I'm not saying those
are the lucky ones,
but those seem to be the ones
that evolution has thrown up
to succeed in the 21st century.
So sorry, anybody
who has Asperger's,
but you probably
don't know you do.
Is this starting off badly?
PETER READ: This is perfect.
Great.
Yeah, it's great.
Yeah.
RUBY WAX: So if
risk was natural,
then we would be able
to be in that state.
But as humans, we have
a lot of glitches.
I know we think we're Homo
perfectest, but we aren't.
So if I explain a
little bit about to me
what-- not the
enemy is, but where
we are so far in my
stand in your way
for being brave
enough, I suppose,
to believe in your own ideas
and follow them through.
So the reason I called
the book "Frazzled"
is because we all need stress.
Let's get that out of the way.
Otherwise we'd still be
sitting on our porch in Alabama
playing the banjo.
But the stress is-- that's fine.
And I'll explain why.
Otherwise you wouldn't
have the oomph.
But the frazzled
bit is when we start
to think about
stress, when we start
get into these loop
tapes of, oh, my god,
I shouldn't be stressed.
We get caught in those stories.
And there never is an
answer, by the way,
like why aren't I thinner?
No answer.
Even Einstein
couldn't answer that.
But getting caught
in those loop tapes
is what keeps you up
all night and what
gives you that red mist
so all creativity shuts
down immediately.
Want me to explain a little
bit about the history of why
we're kind of fucked now?
Would you like that?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
RUBY WAX: OK, you might know
this, but stress, we need it.
Otherwise we wouldn't
be sitting here.
First of all, hundreds
of thousands of years
ago, we were stressed, but we
weren't frazzled because we
didn't have language.
Right?
So you couldn't give
yourself those bad reviews,
like, you know that cave
painting you did yesterday?
Well, it sucked.
So we couldn't do it.
But back then when we
were in the bush-- hunters
and gatherers, and my
people, the pointers,
the Jews-- we just pointed
and we became early shoppers--
but we were perfectly fine,
adjusted to the environment.
But then when a
predator came along--
please tell me if you know
this-- we weren't in charge.
But to save ourselves
from extinction,
this part in our brain
called the amygdala would
sound an alarm and
it would shoot out
this cortisol and adrenaline.
And that's our fight
and flight, by the way.
We always use these
words, but you
don't think that
there's actually
a correspondence in your brain.
When you learn
piano, it's not just
because your fingers learned.
Something develops in your
brain to give you that skill.
So fight and flight is
the gushing of cortisol.
Then if we survived, it would
immediately go down again.
And we'd go back to hunting
and back to the day job.
Just like when you see
an [INAUDIBLE] film
and the gazelle gets
away from a lion,
it doesn't suddenly have
to go to crisis workshops
or take anti-depressants.
It just goes back to grazing.
I have a whole thing
that these days we're
always stressed because,
A, we're being bombarded
by bad news day and night.
The amygdala can't
if there's something
dangerous behind it or something
is happening 20,000 miles away.
It can't tell the difference.
I'm not saying we
don't need the news,
but suddenly I'm
wired because there's
an earthquake in
dung-fung-fung--
like I should know.
Or a whale has been
beached in Malawi.
What can I do?
Get an airplane ticket
and a tow truck?
And then when you get there, I
don't know what to do with it.
You push it in.
You push it out.
You roll it over.
You milk it.
I don't know.
But the enemy is this
feeling of being overwhelmed,
never shuts down.
I'm not good enough.
I'm not fast enough.
I'm not rich enough,
enough, enough.
And by the way, I don't
mean to go off piece,
but these things
are all invisible.
There is something
visible now and none of us
are using our fight
and flight-- the fact
that Donald Trump might be
the leader of the free world.
And what are we doing about it?
This is a guy who used
to have one nose hair
and wind it around his head.
Now he's got an albino
ferret on his head,
and we're just sitting around.
The president may end up
with roadkill on his head.
I'm going off the subject.
And people say, is it technology
that's driving us nuts?
You know I'm sick of this
because we put it there.
It didn't drop from Mars.
And I thank god every
day that at 2 o'clock
in the morning at the
click of a finger,
I can get a husband
or a chocolate bidet.
And I dream.
My dream is that
some day a drone
will be able to come
in and shave my legs.
So the problem is that
it's the speed of it.
And we aren't equipped to
keep up with that speed.
Humans always had
that go-getter thing.
We migrated because
we were hungry.
So we got up and
went to Mongolia.
Then they ran out of food.
We got this naturally.
Then we went to America.
Suddenly there was
a buffalo buffet,
and we just ate
till it was extinct.
We kept going.
The problem is now
it's virtual migration.
And the thing about
humans, again,
is to understand we
never get satiated.
And I think you
probably know this
that every day-- is this
true-- that every day we
create a quintillion
amounts of information--
quintillion bytes of
information-- every day.
Do you know what that is?
It's a one with
18 zeros after it.
So no wonder we're wired.
So I'm not saying shut it off.
But we have to learn some
way to navigate the noise.
I was interested
in that because, A,
I wasn't just getting wired,
but I have depression.
So I wanted to
figure out, is there
some way I don't have
to run to shrinks
and give them my bank account?
Is there some way I
could self-regulate?
I happened to find out because
the scientific journals-- maybe
you have your own
way-- that mindfulness
and cognitive-based therapy
had the best results.
Otherwise, I would have
been-- if it was tree-hugging,
I would have taken that up.
But you can actually see
it in a brain scanner.
If you do a-- if you
start to practice this,
the amygdala shrinks.
I don't believe in
anything unless I
can see it or taste it because
I can't take the fluffy stuff.
So because I have an
extreme amount of dopamine.
Well, I've got that
go-getter thing, which
is good news because
you get great jobs,
but the bad news is it makes
me crash and burn into a wall.
So I hunted down
one of the founders
of mindfulness-based
cognitive therapy.
He was a professor at Oxford.
I'm a driven woman.
So I said, give me what
happens in the brain.
I just don't want
to believe this.
And I don't have time to sit.
I don't even have time to take
a shower, so sometimes I don't.
Don't tell anybody.
Nobody has time.
I said, so I want to know
what happens in the brain.
He said, you'd have to get into
Oxford and get your master's.
And so I did.
And I graduated three years ago.
I wish my mother knew.
I'd have to dig her up.
Don't say anybody I said that.
That was awful.
I don't know what's about
to come out of my mouth
until I hear it.
So that's why I
became so fascinated.
At least it's a braking system.
I'm sure there's others.
There will be biofeedback.
And we'll talk about mindfulness
like it's the dark ages.
But it's all I know.
So would you like to
know how it works?
Because it's all I
know at this point.
All right.
Go with me on this.
If you don't want to go with
me, get back on your computer
because I know how
tempting that is.
Really, I know the addiction.
Believe me, I'm up at 2
o'clock in the morning.
My fingers are having an
orgy on those keyboards.
It's so hard to shut it off.
People write, dear Ruby.
I'm already on it.
And then I hate them because
they don't write me back.
And then I hate them
even more because then I
have to answer those fuckers.
I even start scraping
around to answer spam.
You know what I'm talking about.
So the way mindfulness works--
I'll do the scientific version
because that makes
me look smart-- is,
I pointed out already, we always
have the racing mind always.
The racing mind is
the fight and flight
because we got language now.
So where we used to be vigilant
for the enemy, now the voices,
the thoughts have
replaced, oh, my god, I'm
going to get caught.
Oh, my god, I'm not good enough.
We pretty much-- my
mother was right.
That's a long-playing
album in my head.
So you understand
that's the amygdala.
So picture it.
If you take your focus to one
of your senses-- you don't have
to buy them on Amazon--
taste, sound, smell,
touch-- immediately the
racing thoughts calm down.
You can't have both.
Think of it mechanically.
So because there's no words
when you feel something.
So if you want to--
should I stand up--
if you want to give
a taste for this--
I know this is a little
baby, but just go with me.
It's either gabbling
or it's a sense.
Maybe I'll sit down.
It's too scary.
All right.
So put your hands out.
And when I count to three,
clap them really hard.
And then just hold
them up and try
to keep your mind on the sense.
If you're thinking
takes over, that's cool.
Take it back to the sense,
just focusing on it.
So one, two, three. [CLAP]
So you'll notice, you're
trying to think is it tingly?
Just sense that it is.
And which finger is tingling
or throbbing or it's warm?
So you go, thumbs, pointing
fingers, third finger,
fourth, fifth.
And then gradually-- gradually--
you'll notice it fades away.
Now this isn't mindfulness.
It's like playing the scales
before you play Rachmaninoff.
And the point of
mindfulness isn't
to become a better clapper.
It's the minute you start
focusing on any sense,
your brain cools down, the
amygdala, the [INAUDIBLE].
And that's the only way you
can watch your thoughts is
if you're cool, which
is to do with resilience
because until you can
cool your brain down--
I don't care how you do
it-- get that cortisol down.
And there's probably
Fitbits that
will show you how to
do it, though they're
in the dark ages, too.
But the point isn't just to
notice, oh, it's gone down,
but we need to
watch our thoughts.
Otherwise we're sleepwalking.
Because that's when
you're creative.
You need to be able to focus in
on what you're thinking rather
than just-- because if
you're not watching them,
you won't notice when they
snare you and they get
caught in that rumination.
So it's as if you're the shrink.
Now you watch when
they start to go.
At least you've got a stopgap
especially if you're about--
you're trying to-- you know
you're getting a writer's-- I
get a writer's block.
Pull it to a focus.
And the more you do
it, the easier it gets.
And I start to get a different
relationship with my thoughts.
I start to name them rather
than be at the mercy of them.
So sometimes I go, oh,
that's track number
52, which is everybody
knows I'm a fraud.
Or track number 75, which
is, they're looking at me,
but they're not
really listening.
Now this may be true, but
at least the minute you
become the watcher, the
minute you start watching,
actually the
cortisol comes down.
If you want another scientific
version of why that happens,
again, if you understand a
little bit about the brain,
you don't have to
become a neurosurgeon,
but understand
that when you take
this focus from the
amygdala to the insula,
there's no muscles
in your brain,
but you're building
up more gray matter.
Just go with me on this.
Which means more and
more neural connections,
which is making you resilient
Let's call it the
scientific version.
Let's just call it gloop.
That's my name.
So each time you take
the focus, that insula
is getting more and more gloop.
So when the shit
hits the fan, you've
got that resilience, or
at least my version of it.
So it's easier to
pull to a sense.
You're not going to stay there.
But let me just tell you, if
you're getting that red mist,
and you can't think anymore,
if you learn to pull it back,
you're not vegging out.
But when you go back
in, just like a car
or just like rebooting
your computer,
you've got more resilience
than the next guy.
So actually it's quite
good for business.
And if you don't understand
the gloop, everything you learn
is by gray matter.
If you are memorizing
something, the reason you do it
over and over and
over again, it's
not because you're getting more
filing cabinets in your head.
It's because that particular
area of the memory
is building up more
and more gloop.
That's how you learn the piano.
That's how you learn
how to do a backhand.
And by the way, you
have to practice it.
Everything you learn, if you
think about it-- calculus, how
to walk, how to talk,
how to pole dance--
is because you repeat it
over and over and over again.
It's the practice that does it.
So if you want to do a
mindfulness exercise now,
want to do it?
All right.
Now this is making more gloop.
Obviously not just
today, but keep it up.
All right.
So, again, this is the exercise.
Come away from the
back of your chair.
You just do this for a minute.
And by the way, nobody
has time to do this,
but when you're in a queue,
when you're-- I don't know--
sitting on the bus, sitting on
the-- you all have waiting time
when you're walking
down the hallway.
Even a minute of this becoming
aware builds the gloop.
All right.
So take your focus to a sense.
And let's start with
the sense that's
as far from your gabbling
brain as you can.
So take your focus to
where are your feet.
If you can, touch the ground
so you feel the contact
of your foot on the ground.
Everybody can do that.
And you're going to want
to think, but that's cool.
Just take it back to the sense.
OK, let it go.
And if you didn't register
anything, it doesn't matter.
Now focus on where your body is
making contact with the chair.
So you feel the whole
outline and the inside
your skin where
it's making contact,
so you really feel the
effects of gravity.
So just let that focus go.
And now take your focus
to the sense of sound.
So all you're
doing is listening.
And your mind's
going to take you.
Believe me, in a
couple seconds, you're
going to get snared
by your thoughts.
Maybe you're thinking
about-- I don't
know-- the future, the past,
a fantasy, getting angry.
As soon as you notice it, you
haven't done anything wrong.
You just notice it.
And then that without giving
yourself a hard time at all
because everybody's minds
do it, take your focus back
to listening.
And then your thoughts will
take you at some point.
Again, don't whip
yourself about it.
Just take it back again.
Another sense, if
you want, is just
let the sound go
and take your focus
to where you notice
that you're breathing,
either whatever your
area's most vivid,
through the tip of your nose,
your throat, your chest,
your abdomen.
And stay with it.
Just try to focus on where
your air is going in and out.
And then your mind's
going to take you.
You have to do something.
You didn't do something.
You should do-- whatever
you're thinking,
you just go, OK, I noticed it.
Good.
No judgment.
Go back to where
you were breathing.
And if you have trouble
tracking your breath,
see if you can count to five.
This isn't a contest.
It's easier to be more specific.
So in breath, out breath is one.
In breath, out breath, two.
And if you lose your way, you
haven't done anything wrong,
just go back to one.
And if you don't get to
five, it's not a contest.
So in breath, out breath, one.
So another thing this
does is it teaches
you to pay attention, which goes
back to resilience and risk,
is that whatever else is the
racing mind, is that really,
again, there's a
part in your brain--
I could tell you the
name of it-- that
is in charge of attention.
By the way, I'm
making it simplistic.
But it really is your
anterior cingulate
cortex is getting the gloop
so that you really learn.
You're practicing how to--
you don't do it all day.
You don't do sit-ups all day.
It's just a short amount
of time, even a minute.
But even that has an effect when
they look in a brain scanner.
So each time you
bring the focus,
you're sharpening the
ability to pay attention.
And people go, well,
what's with attention?
I pay it, OK?
Well, you don't.
Actually, as humans, we
can only pay attention
to something for
1.2 seconds and then
we flit away because our
minds, believe it or not,
are still caveman.
It doesn't understand
that there's
been some redecoration
for the 21st century.
So really all we're geared
for is to see what's dangerous
and what's safe.
That's it.
We really aren't equipped
to pick one toothpaste out
of 5,000 choices.
So it's either a
snake or it's a stick.
And what also, I
think-- this, I think,
is interesting-- is wherever
you pay attention defines
who you are in that second.
So if you're sitting
in the computer,
but your mind is
off on a holiday,
you're not actually
at the computer.
Everything in your
brain is somewhere else.
I know that because I
actually experienced it.
I was in the was in
Melbourne two years ago.
And the sun was eclipsing.
And it happens only
once every 200 years.
But my brain is-- I'm shouting
at the White Company in London
because somebody sent me
a single duvet instead
of the king size.
That's where my brain is.
I'm thinking, right?
The sun is eclipsed.
The moon is going
in front of the sun.
It's going to happen
in another 199 years.
And I am tearing somebody's
neck off because he sent me
the wrong duvet.
So you know what I'm thinking?
If I die in the
next second, do I
want my mind to have been
in the White Company?
Well, if there's a 20%
sale, then I don't mind.
Actually-- I don't
know if I have
time-- I could talk a little
bit about-- how much time
have I got?
Not much.
PETER READ: Yeah.
RUBY WAX: You want a little
bit about neuroplasticity
is that they used to think our
brains were locked in stone.
The way you come into the
world is how you go out.
But now they know it's
constantly shapeshifting.
Every experience you have,
even your genes, are affected.
We aren't locked.
I mean, you're never
going to be an-- well,
you probably are--
you're never going
to be an Einstein if you
don't have the genes,
but there's a lot of elbow room.
It's constantly moving around.
It's like pass the parcel,
except it's not some crap gift.
It's passing chemicals
through electric transmitters.
So if you're very tense, it's
starting to pass that cortisol.
That's how it goes.
And then we freeze.
That's what happens.
And we go into that other
thing besides fight and flight.
We freeze.
And this is where
you get people who
start to-- because
we hate uncertainty.
That really is the
natural condition.
And when we feel
it, we actually--
our version of freezing is we
start to stick to stereotypes.
Like, people will say, oh, I'm
a victim, which you aren't.
I mean, we're everything.
But it's better,
the devil you know.
They've actually put
scanners on people's eyes.
Are we at zero?
Man, we didn't have time
for question and answer.
And they will always
look for the perpetrator.
So, basically, if
those neurons, if you
start to learn how
to cool your engine,
if you really start to
be able to self-regulate
your chemicals,
then you can really
navigate around the slings and
arrows of outrageous fortune.
But literally, the only way to
do it is coming to your senses.
So I'm kind of done,
but we don't have
time for question and answer.
PETER READ: No, I think we do.
Sasha, I think we do?
Yeah.
RUBY WAX: How much?
20?
Oh, well, then I could go on.
No, I won't go on.
PETER READ: Go on.
RUBY WAX: I won't go on.
PETER READ: Do you
want to ask a question?
I mean, ask
questions on anything
we've said and then also maybe,
as we said earlier, bringing it
back together around
this theme of how can
we harness technology to
solve mental well-being
with the hardware or software.
RUBY WAX: Yeah?
Oh, I think you have
to get up there,
but I think we can hear you.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so--
RUBY WAX: Can you hear him?
OK.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So in your opinion,
how does subconscious
fit into this context?
How do you view subconscious?
So I'm saying again--
RUBY WAX: How do you
view the subconscious?
You mean in a Freudian sense?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so do you think
that a subconscious, there's
something else that even
if we think about it,
but when we go to sleep,
there's something else that's
going on beyond our control?
RUBY WAX: Well,
I think you can--
I think it's a little
bit old-fashioned
that we have to analyze it.
It's a little bit like looking
at what your body produces
and trying to figure
out the source of it.
If you start to
delve into what it
is-- sorry for any
Freudian-- you're actually
embedding it more and more.
And then you do come up,
I'm an alcoholic, I'm this.
You get a story.
But memory doesn't
work like that.
Memory works like photocopies.
So eventually, why
hold on to that?
So the thing about
mindfulness is
that you're allowing the
thoughts to come and go.
I suppose that's
your unconscious.
It's pornographic.
It's adorable.
It's cruel.
You're starting
to get a distance.
And again, if you
let it go, you start
to notice it's never
going to shut off
even before you go to sleep.
People think the
point of mindfulness
is that you go blank.
Your mind is blank
when you're dead.
That's a big clue
that you're dead.
You're blank.
So you're actually-- and
it's a misconception--
you're allowing this hell--
and it's always awful.
Always I get up in the morning
and believe me it's Armageddon.
But gradually you learn it's
a radio in another room.
Like right now, if I shut up,
boy, would I be getting hell.
Intimidation isn't in it.
But eventually, you
learn to live with it.
You go, oh, yeah, come on in.
Fine.
And when you get that
relationship-- actually,
if you get the distance, the
minute that cortisol is down,
resilience, risk,
everything takes
place because nobody is
frightening you anymore.
The only thing that's
frightening are our thoughts.
Nobody can hurt you.
It's your thoughts that can
really put you in a bad place.
PETER READ: Just
to add to that, I
think the Daniel Kahneman
behavioral economics
stuff, which he
explicitly recognizes
that the role of
subconscious, system
one in our economic
behavior, is some
of the most powerful
insights in economics
over the last couple of decades.
RUBY WAX: Tell them
the name of the book.
PETER READ: Daniel Kahneman.
RUBY WAX: "Thinking,
Fast and Slow."
PETER READ: "Thinking,
Any others?
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: I had a quick
question about sleep.
RUBY WAX: Can he come closer?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, can
you hear me now?
I had a question about
sleep and whether you
could chat a little bit on how,
since obtaining your degree,
you've been able to apply
your new knowledge to becoming
a better sleeper,
assuming that you weren't
a brilliant one before,
and any practical advice
for the insomniacs in the crowd.
RUBY WAX: Well,
first of all listen
to our Russell
Foster on Ted Talks
because he's the
expert of experts.
And far worse than
any, within limit,
drugs, if you
don't sleep enough,
that cortisol will
crash you to the ground.
And by the way, some
people go, oh, yeah, I'm
a little stressed.
Yeah, I can deal with it.
I can take it on.
You can't take it on.
If it keeps going, it won't
just lead to insomnia.
Every disease is caused by
that-- diabetes, cancer,
obesity, drug addiction,
mental illness, infertility.
So I'm just saying be scared,
stay up a little later.
I think that again, if you do
something like mindfulness,
and if you don't want
to do-- by the way,
it isn't for everybody--
is it becomes a habit.
And they teach kids now.
It's something
called beditation.
If you really practice this
thing-- and if it doesn't work,
find something that does.
I don't care if you take
Xanax once in a while.
Or I've learned
mindfulness means you learn
what it is that works for you.
Don't imitate the next guy
who sleeps three hours.
Most of us really need it.
Maybe you can't take the time,
but this is another thing
about understanding.
No matter what job you
have, if you're tired,
you'll notice you
can't be creative.
So if you practice
this, don't just
pull the ripcord when
you can't go to sleep
or when I know I'm
getting depressed.
If you just do it once, it's
like you can't do one sit-up.
But if you keep
practicing, there
is a way, again, of lower-- the
racing thoughts won't happen.
But the reason you go to
sleep is they continue.
They continue.
You know that thing.
And gradually you go from--
what-- alpha to theta.
I mean, it will happen.
But you can't just
do it once, even
if you grab a minute a day.
But if it doesn't work
for you, experiment.
Again, try everything.
PETER READ: There's actually
an interesting parallel.
So to what Ruby was
describing earlier,
when she went to
Oxford, she learned
mindfulness-based
cognitive therapy.
So a branch of CBT from
Professor Mark Williams.
Another professor at
Oxford, Colin Espie,
actually has a
company called Sleepio
in which I'm an investor, so
I'm not objective on this.
But it is delivering sleep-based
CBT digitally, and then
actually a whole
bunch of other stuff.
So it's actually
a similar branch.
It all starts in cognitive
behavioral therapy.
RUBY WAX: See, technology
is going to rule.
PETER READ: So its, in a
way, a perfect example.
RUBY WAX: And the
results are unbelievable.
PETER READ: It's very powerful.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PETER READ: Oh, brilliant.
For thos of you who
didn't hear, all Googlers
have access to the Sleepio
thing, which is good.
AUDIENCE: I was going
to ask a question.
PETER READ: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You said a few
times that we're in Stone Age
as far as mental health and
mindfulness is concerned.
What do you see
or hope the future
is with mindfulness
and mental health?
RUBY WAX: Oh, you
want to go first?
PETER READ: Yeah.
So I think this is the
stuff-- and, actually,
this is a question that
we would like to ask you--
which is, how do we
harness technology
to help us solve mental
well-being as we said earlier?
And we've talked
about it before.
There are two flavors of this.
One is, if you like,
a hardware flavor.
Is there a Fitbit for the mind?
And what does that look like?
Where does it sit?
Does it sit on your wrist?
And that would be
something, probably,
that could measure heart rate
variability very accurately
because that's the best proxy
for the amount of cortisol
in the system.
Come back to that.
And then the second is when
Ruby mentioned it earlier,
when she was talking
about track 17
and track-- is there software,
machine-learning software, that
can help me objectively
recognize those soundtracks--
maybe before I'm
recognizing them--
or maybe before I'm allowing
myself to believe, oh, gosh,
yeah, it is that
soundtrack again.
So again, that feels to me
more like is there a software
solution, and AI-based
software solution
that can recognize those
soundtracks before I do?
So those are the two.
I don't know-- to go
back to the first,
if I can take your question
and make it another question,
is has anybody seen anything
like that, a piece of hardware
that is going to be able
to accurately measure heart
rate variability, for example?
Anybody seen that?
RUBY WAX: Is that your
area, by the way, at all,
of looking at the hardware
that would maybe say-- see,
it's the wrong--
PETER READ: Yeah, probably
less so, actually, right?
RUBY WAX: I think it's
an engineer thing.
PETER READ: Other bits
of Google do-- yeah.
RUBY WAX: What do you think?
Yeah.
PETER READ: Yeah, probably.
RUBY WAX: We're wasting
our breath [INAUDIBLE].
PETER READ: And then
the software side,
the AI side, again, does
that resonate with you
as something that
enables you to recognize
those patterns in your own
mind, maybe even before you do?
RUBY WAX: To me, the
problem with all this
is I understand you can check
how quick you're running,
though to me that--
or how many steps
you do-- but to me, that
leads to a nervous breakdown.
Oh, my god, I
didn't do my 2,000.
So it raises up the
cortisol even more
though you may
have run whatever.
But what we're
missing here, and I
think what it
should incorporate,
is the practice isn't just
to notice the cortisol.
The practice is to
give you insight.
And also, I mean,
it's infinite to help
you get into the present,
though that sounds slushy.
But if you think it
does, ask yourself
how much money you spend to get
there if you go to a restaurant
and go to the-- buy
that wine that's
from the
[NONSENSE SOUND] valley.
If you don't taste it, you might
as well cut out the middleman
and pour it into the toilet.
Somebody said if you
can ask somebody what's
the best time in their
lives and they say now,
then they've arrived.
The main thing is to
recognize who you are.
I mean, that was
always know thyself.
And it still stands.
If, when you're in the
midst of a situation,
you don't recognize what's
going on in your head,
it'll happen over
and over again.
The practice is to
see, to understand.
Sometimes I know
I'm cooking on gas
because I write for "AbFab."
And I'm crash-- if you think
getting brain freeze is bad,
if you're trying to be
funny the first thing that
goes, with a little bit of
stress, forget about it.
You can't.
Because the whole thing is
about getting out of the box.
But sometimes I use mindfulness.
I let the bullshit
go by, the crap,
how awful I am, how I've never
written a funny line, who
do I think I am.
And gradually, it's like
something rises out of the mud.
They say your most
inspiration comes from when
you're taking a shower.
Get in the shower, I suppose,
but you might be at work.
It ain't going to happen.
Oh, no, you have showers here.
But out of the mud suddenly
comes the most creative thing.
The heart's down.
The risk thing is cooking.
And out of that dirt
suddenly rises up.
So you can use it
for creative thought.
So
Just to use it to get down,
to get that alpha state,
that's not what
we're aiming for.
When you run, it doesn't matter.
You can run mindlessly.
And by the way, to me,
that's not the answer.
You can run mindfully,
but you have
to read my book to do that.
Not pushing it,
but I'm pimping it.
But you can use it
for various things.
So, basically, I think
what we were talking about
is that even with
this new hardware,
somebody has to be very
careful because again we'll
be chasing the wrong rabbit.
The point of this is
to understand yourself.
When you're sitting there and
you can't burn out anymore,
you can't take any more, look
where your tipping point is.
What are you thinking?
Otherwise, you'll never learn
where your tipping point is.
There's a moment where
you know that it starts
to curve down and
then learn to go--
that'll help you go to sleep
if you keep acknowledging
your tipping point.
I'm sure you won't get fired
because once you recognize it,
you take a rest.
This should be in the hardware.
Your computer starts to
say-- it doesn't say,
but it starts to slow down
and it's replaced by--
I don't care if it's
your cat purring--
I've actually recorded my
cat-- but there's a moment.
You know what I mean, a sound
or a smell, work for you.
But I think that's the future.
So run with that idea.
I listen to jungle nosies.
I swear to God.
It cools me right down.
But don't do it
while you're driving.
AUDIENCE: Advertising tries
to get people's attention.
So it tries to take you from
what you're doing, what you're
thinking about, and
draw your attention
to whatever the objective
of the advertiser is.
A lot of us work in advertising.
What do you think about
the effects of advertising
on mindfulness?
And what is the
responsibility of companies
like Google, Facebook towards
advocating mindfulness?
RUBY WAX: Do you
want to go first?
PETER READ: Yeah, so who's
the Nobel economist who talks
about the attention economy?
I've totally forgotten now.
I always find that an
incredibly helpful way
to start thinking about this
because that is advertising's
job, is to grab my attention.
And the way I've thought about
it for myself is, actually,
if you put yourself through
digital detox, which I don't
know if-- has anybody tried
that, by the way, just as
an exercise with this health?
Yeah, sort of 10% of the room.
RUBY WAX: What kind
of a risk was that?
Boy.
I would think that's
the highest risk of all.
PETER READ: Right.
So when you do that, and
you actually deliberately
starve yourself of those
attention distractions
from advertising,
then you realize--
and for me, it was
only then that I
realized what a great job
you guys do distracting
me most of the time.
RUBY WAX: Oo, was
that a backhander.
PETER READ: No, it's
entirely a compliment.
So that, for me,
was the recognition
that I am much more
distracted by this,
that you have done a great
job of drawing my attention.
And so, in order to fight
that for me, I need to unplug,
which I don't do a
great job of, but I'm
at least conscious of it and
try to do it from time to time.
That answer it a little bit?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, great.
And what is our
responsibility as [INAUDIBLE]?
RUBY WAX: So I was going to
say, raising kids or being
with your friends or your
relationships at work, is you
have to walk the talk because
we work like neural Wi-Fi.
So if I can cool myself
down, it has a ripple effect.
So I think if you
understood what
it is to not be distracted
and not get nervous,
that it's job's worth,
I think you might
start thinking out of the box.
Because part of the thing
that distraction does
is it might not even buy your
product or whatever is it
makes people
nervous, which means
they're not thinking clearly.
So they really
won't focus on what
it is you're trying to get over,
you're trying to get across.
And believe me, if you
think you're distracted,
it will reflect in what
you're trying to push.
I've done things last
week for call centers.
And I said, don't
assume what worked
in the past is going to work
now because people can sense it,
even over the thing.
They can sense that
you're doing a quick fix.
But they can also
sense-- I'm doing it
more person to person--
is that when you're
really interested in that
person, if you're curious,
that's the key to their heart.
So I don't know how you do it.
But it's almost
like you know how
we start by asking questions and
sort of letting them figure it
out.
It's your humanity and
it's your curiosity.
If you're really curious and
you're trying to get in--
and you're really
learning to pay attention,
then they'll give you
the keys to their car,
their wife, their money.
I don't know how you
do that digitally.
But I think if you
practice something
where your life is a
series of distractions
and you really
learn to listen, it
might-- maybe you'll
have group meetings--
inspire you to do something
where you really hook somebody.
I don't know what that is
because it's not my job.
But it has to start with you.
PETER READ: And we
all know what that
feels like when
we're in a-- my wife
is one of those people who,
if you ask my children or any
of our friends, she is
one of those people who
when she's present
in a conversation,
she's incredibly present.
And she doesn't practice
mindfulness to get there.
RUBY WAX: Yeah, she's a natural.
PETER READ: She's a natural.
You know her.
She's a natural.
Some people can do that.
So it is a very--
it's very precious.
RUBY WAX: Maybe you ask
people what they want.
And then you sculpt
what you're giving.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I've been practicing for about,
I think, a year and a half,
almost every day.
And something that
I find is, even
though I think in the long
term it's been very beneficial,
I sometimes struggle
with increased anxiety
as a result of this increased
sense of being present.
Because sometimes you're
so present that when
you run into these
cycles of anxiety,
it just perpetrates into
more and more and more.
How do you deal with that?
Because it's something
that I have, like I said,
found very useful over
the course of time,
but then sometimes
it is very-- yeah,
you're almost too present.
RUBY WAX: Yeah, I got that.
But, again, mindfulness
means that you're
taking the temperature.
You're the barometer.
If it's too much-- I
always say, if you're
in the midst of burnout or
if you're in depression,
do not go near this.
So mindfulness is-- the
big thing in bold print
is be nice to yourself.
Go in the gym.
Maybe you can't because
you broke your arm,
but go in the gym.
Distract yourself.
There's moments where
you need distractions,
just like there's moments
when you need stress.
But, again, you
don't want it to be
like you listen to lovely
music or there's nothing.
I meditate.
Go on the tube because
you learn to tolerate.
And to tolerate is the
way kids will survive.
It's a muscle.
But, again, you'll see
your tipping point.
When it's driving
you nuts, get up.
AUDIENCE: Fair enough.
And, I think, a
follow-up question.
You were saying before about
how you gauge co-founders
in terms of their resilience and
their ability to manage stress.
Who else do you see doing that?
Is that something
you'd say is somewhat
widespread amongst
funds and people
trying to invest in start-ups,
gauging the ability of founders
to be resilient to
take on leadership
through to stress
management, et cetera?
PETER READ: Yeah, I think
everybody who does what I do
will do their own version
of that because it's
sort of obvious, isn't it?
Again, if in my world
it's not so much
that we cherish the idea, it's
that we cherish the ability
to get something done.
And so how do people
get something done even
when the doors all
seem to be closed?
Well, then you want
to back founders
who will climb through the
window if the door's closed.
On your earlier
point, I was going
to say there is a temptation
for-- well, a couple of points.
One is that
meditation, like yoga,
can sometimes start to become
competitive in some random way.
How long do you do it for?
All this kind of stuff, which
is generally less hopeful.
And a second is a slightly
more philosophical point here,
which is that I think everybody
I know who has been meditating,
practicing mindfulness for
a long time comes to a point
where-- and I think a
lot of Mark Williams
and others did an amazing
job of helping bring it
into the scientific
realm out of-- bring it
into the scientific realm
and wrap it in neuroscience.
But Mark and others
will also tell you
that there comes a point
where actually it's helpful
if it's slightly pushed
back into an ethical realm
so that you're not just doing
it because it's great to shrink
your amygdala, that in addition
that it is somehow helping
you think about what's
good, and that it has
some kind of ethical
vector through it
as well as just pure ability
to focus your attention
on the present moment.
See what I mean?
RUBY WAX: I think
that's from-- I
know I put it in small
brackets, but when
you notice that your
mind is flipping,
part of the habit breaking
is being nice to yourself,
kind, or whatever,
or compassionate.
It's, again, I always think
of a horrible greeting card.
But that's the training.
So that when you start to
recognize how cruel you are
to yourself, part of
it is to understand
when somebody else
is giving you hell,
they're listening
to a recording, too.
So you stop taking
it so personally.
So again, the point isn't to
sit on a gluten-free cushion.
The point is that you're
now recognizing yourself
in other people, or that we're
all in the same situation.
That's, again, not
in the small print,
but I always have
trouble with the C
word, which is compassion.
AUDIENCE: Great answer.
Thank you.
RUBY WAX: I think
that's a side project.
AUDIENCE: I have a slightly
follow-on question.
So can you talk us
through an example
or give advice or
maybe tell a story
of when this happened that
you get to that tipping point,
you're frazzled,
you're overwhelmed,
but there's still the issue
that it's not fully socially
acceptable-- or sometimes
it is acceptable,
but you don't feel it
is-- to put your hand up
and say, I've got
too much on my plate.
I can't cope.
And we still-- obviously, we
work in a very accepting place,
but there's still
commitments to be had.
There's still meetings
to show up to.
You still have to turn
up to work tomorrow
even though sometimes you
don't feel like you can.
And that bit is sometimes
hard to break through.
PETER READ: She wrote a book
about this-- two, in fact.
RUBY WAX: I know you can't.
I can't stop, either.
But let's say I'm doing a show.
I'm doing a show.
So I grab a minute backstage.
Or you'll grab a minute.
I don't care.
There is a minute,
especially if you're going
to have a meeting or something.
I'm not saying stop
what you're doing.
As a matter of fact,
there's now books
that show you how to be
present while you're doing
your work, which is noticing.
It's always noticing
the state of mind
and going back to maybe
looking at what you're doing.
But the exercise is,
where is your mind?
Bring it back.
Where is your mind?
And as far as work, when
you do go into a meeting
and it's getting
tense, if you recognize
when you're locking antlers
and this meeting isn't going
anywhere, I wish
they would really
learn to hold up a white
flag and say, we're just
caught in that animal cycle.
I think, again, if you
learn while you're there,
and because you practiced
to cool it down--
I'm sure that's why Arabs
use those beads because it's
splitting their attention.
If you learn to do it in
the situation-- walking,
being in the gym, eating can
be a time to do the exercise.
So you don't have
to take time off.
Just that one minute.
You can see the results.
If somebody does it 3 and
1/2 hours, it already shows.
Does that answer your question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, thank you.
PETER READ: It is a
very hard thing to do,
isn't it, to put your
hand up and say, I--
RUBY WAX: You don't have to
put your hand up, though.
PETER READ: Right.
RUBY WAX: It's a personal thing.
You don't have to
admit to anybody.
Hopefully, you're
avoiding burnout
by doing this kind of thing.
And, again, for
technology, I know
there shouldn't be a buzzer
because it'll get people
into competing going,
I shut off first.
But, again, if it could
be replaced by whatever
it is that cools you down--
because you need a reminder.
That's the thing.
When we get frazzled,
how do you pull out?
I think it's practice.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
SPEAKER 1: Unfortunately, we've
come to the end of our hour
now.
But Ruby and Peter,
thank you so--
RUBY WAX: Thank you.
SPEAKER 1: --so much for
coming today and talking to us.
[APPLAUSE]
PETER READ: Thank you.
RUBY WAX: Thank you.